I'd like to introduce Paul Marcus who's
our deputy director at the Stanford
center for professional development he
will be introducing today's speakers you
thank you very much and welcome to this
webinar we're pleased to have you here
today and we have two terrific faculty
members it's my good pleasure to
introduce bill burr naxos consulting
assistant professor of mechanical
engineering bill has been working in
this domain for quite some time he's
currently the executive director of
design program and he manages the
undergraduate and graduate program in
design at Stanford both the joint
program between mechanical engineering
and the art department in those areas he
received his BS and ms and product
design at Stanford as we're professional
in a wide variety of projects ranging
from award-winning Apple portable
computers to the hasbro star wars action
figures he holds a number of mechanical
and design patents and design awards for
a variety of products including the
first true slate computer in addition to
his duties at Stanford he serves on the
board of d2 m a product design
consultancy dhalsim energy an
alternative energy company focused on
developing biomass gasification energy
systems for small-scale municipalities
and advises several startups in really
the company and design strategy bill
welcome to the session I also have the
pleasure of introducing Chris dirties is
an associate professor of mechanical
engineering in the design group and the
director of the Center for Automotive
Research at Stanford and the co-director
of the Center for design research
correct Chris directs the design lab and
is a co-founder of the center
affectionately known as cars now this is
where Stanford is bringing automobile
companies such as Volkswagen Audi Toyota
together with the best minds in computer
science and artificial intelligence and
cognitive psychology to ask some really
big questions like what does it take for
a car to drive itself orkin texting and
driving be made safe after his
presentation I'm sure Chris would
welcome the opportunity to engage more
affiliate members to his research
Center so if you are interested in that
please let us know or let chris know
chris's current research focuses on the
integrated design and control of
mechanical systems the application of
advanced analysis and control techniques
to ground vehicle design and
specifically to cars the areas of
specific interest for Chris include
advanced driver assistance systems
vehicle diagnostics and control using
GPS and integrated design control of the
combustion system now I'd like to turn
over the floor to Professor bill Burnett
bill thanks Paul I want to talk to you a
little bit to set up Chris's talk about
this thing we're calling design thinking
this is a quote from David Kelly who's
the founder of our new Institute the
d.school where we're doing this
integrated approach to teaching everyone
at the university how to think like a
designer David you'll probably also know
as the founder of I do probably the
largest product innovation and strategic
innovation consultancy in the US and he
and he's he and I and the Design Group
really believe that the next generation
of innovators and business leaders need
to be great design thinkers so if you
look at the way we educate people at
Stanford there's many many different
sort of methods of thinking on campus if
you if you work in the humanities
Department you're probably in a post
rational deconstructionist thinking mode
if you're in the business school you're
being taught business thinking which is
really methods a very kind of
quantitative method of looking at
alternatives and deciding which is them
the better the a or the be maximizing
around net present value or internal
rate of return or strategic significance
to the organization we do it we were in
the engineering school and we do a lot
of engineering thinking engineering
thinking is very rigorous you you try to
isolate a system bound it by a series of
equations isolate the known and unknown
quantities and solve for the unknown but
in a lot of problems you can't bound the
system they're uncontrolled humans are
involved too many subsystems are
involved
and we find that in in problems like
that problems that designers have been
working with all the time because in
design you never know what you're going
to get until you until you start and the
answer is it's more of a sort of an art
of discovering the answer than it is
trying to rationalize to an answer in
design thinking we work on problems that
are poorly bounded and we build our way
forward it's a different way of thinking
and so let me let me talk a little bit
about that of course everybody has a
process we have a five step process
starts with empathy and works all the
way through you know an iterative
process of prototyping but really design
thinking isn't so much about process as
it is about something else this is a
quote that a colleague over in the
business school relayed to me Alan
Mulally's is the CEO of Ford after a
number of attempts to turn forward
around that it was where it just sort of
wasn't working and they were bringing in
the consultants and they were saying oh
well your product development processes
and right you need five tool gates and
then they went on and they tried that
for a while and nothing happened and
they still had that you know bad results
and then they brought in another
consultant so don't know know you needed
seven toll gates you know the process is
the important thing we finally ran into
a young engineer and breakroom had put
up a sign that says culture eats process
for lunch and the point of this was
really that if you don't have a car
culture and Ford had lost its way around
having a car culture a place where
people just love to come to work and
build the best car they knew how to
build and they had sort of devolved into
a process based culture with focus
groups and everything sort of moving to
the middle when you have when you have a
process a tollgate version of process
and you need something like that we're
not arguing that you don't need that but
if you have if you rely solely on
process you end up with results that are
moved immediately to the mean to the
middle and so milele took this to heart
he said we're going to change the
culture the most important thing I can
do is the CEO is not talking about
process but talk about culture and he
changed for back to a culture where
people love to come to work and build
great cars and as you know for it is
probably the more successful of the US
auto companies for it
so we think it's about culture as well
we think it's really about creating a
culture of what we call a culture of
creative confidence if you want to
unlock innovation in an organization
people have to be free to be creative
and creative people act differently than
people who are working inside a process
they tend to break rules they tend to do
things are not supposed to do and they
tend to act in a way that allows them to
express their own sense of self and ego
and once you've got that sort of a
culture going lots of really interesting
things happen the other thing is we put
we started as you saw in the process
slide we start with what empathy we
start with deep dive into the latent
needs of the user community that we're
working with and that's not the same
thing as market research market research
is very important it so the
macroeconomics of your of your market
how many people are there how fast is
the market growing things like that but
that doesn't tell you what people really
need and you have to go out and you have
to be in their environment and study
them and we use the tools of ethnography
and cultural anthropology it's a kind of
a mash-up of a lot of radical
collaboration we bring anthropologists
with us we bring sociologists with us
and we go out in the field and we ask
people questions now people can't tell
you what they need necessarily no one
can tell you oh I need a smartphone it
looks cool and is easy to use and then
well I you've invented you know an
iphone 4 but they can show you what they
can show you and they can tell you what
they're struggling with and what the
problems are and if you focus on needs
we're going to talk a little bit about
the new emerging behaviors and needs in
the car when Chris knocks you can you
can generally come up with some really
startling insights about where the new
opportunities are in your market or in
the product space certainly a culture of
ideas we spend a lot of time at Stanford
educating our young engineers on how to
have better ideas you think these these
these these young students who are very
very bright you know half of the
classes valedictorians in Stanford the
other half have perfect SATs and such
would be very good at having ideas but
in fact their education has been almost
entirely less brain right math science
and verbal and not so much on the right
brain creative intuitive big leaps
visual thinking so we have a class
called any 101 visual thinking and we
have many other ways of sort of
re-engaging their creativity so that
they can feel confident that they can
have hundreds of ideas the typical
engineering thinking is to look for the
one right answer and design we look for
hundreds of right answers it's also a
culture of radical collaboration and
that's something that Chris is going to
talk more about but what's interesting
about this this image here as you see
five people sitting around on some red
couches red couches are sort of the you
know adopted symbol of the d.school we
went down to ikea one day when we didn't
have any money and bought a bunch of
couches and now they've turned out to be
the symbol of this new big international
institution but what you see sitting on
this table is something you would never
see in any other department at Stanford
sitting around this table the gentleman
and the far back left with the gray hair
Bernie Ross is one of the top kinematics
professors in the world also a designer
and an educator on the on the front
right is Terry Winograd one of the top
AI scientists computer scientists
human-computer interaction people in the
world and the woman with the big smile
Tina Selig runs day entrepreneur program
in the management science and
engineering department so you've got
three completely different departments
three senior professors all sitting
around the table collaborating on
designing a new class and you would
never see that happening in any other
part of the university the typical model
for educating everywhere else is one
professor with one subject matter
teaching you know one thing in a lecture
mode all of our classes are taught
problem-based learning style and these
guys are cooking up some really
interesting wicked problems for the
students to work on
it's also cultural prototyping this
notion that you can't know the future so
you build your way forward you build
yourself into the future by trying small
experiments that are low-risk I meant to
fail but are going to provoke new
answers going to collapse the boundary
conditions of the problem around some
very specific examples of what the
future might look like and Chris will
tell you more about that when he talks
about the car project so I'm going
through this quickly but just to give
you a you know kind of a good sense or
an overview design thinking is a
different way of approaching problems
it's actually we spent as much time in
the empathy and ideation phase of design
thinking finding good problems how often
have you in your organization worked
really really really hard and a problem
that you're either given by management
or you perceived to be the correct thing
to work on only to discover after you
had solved it that you are working on
the wrong problem but the real problem
you need to really understand the
problem we needed to zoom back and
understand more of the system and how
the system works together so we think
the big leverage you get out of design
thinking and really what prototyping is
all about is sort of searching for the
right problem but it's also a way of
framing and forming new solutions which
is different from analytic thinking we
rely more on synthesis we look for the
deeper meaning inside a problem need
finding is really not just about finding
what are the use and usability issues
that people have with something why is
it hard to use or how could you make it
easier it's actually really about
finding out what what objects and
products mean to people and there's no
richer area than that and it's one of
the reasons we're so interested in what
cars is doing is that the cop the
automobile has such a deep cultural
meaning in our society that the way the
automobile is changing really reflects
something about what products mean and
it's a very rich area for research so we
rely on synthesis and meaning and
context more than we do on analysis or
data reduction we employed creativity
these creative problem-solving methods
empathy the cultural anthropology and
ethnography of research
the defines a hidden problem in the
situation prototyping an iteration and
we do this multidisciplinary radical
collaboration process because that's
what brings out the sort of rich texture
of the problem when we bring all of the
stakeholders to the table together and
there's this thing called wicked
problems some guys are Berkeley a long
time ago to find this thing an
ill-defined problem which is messy
circular an aggressive and three
solutions are not true or false but
better or worse and also whose solutions
once you once you lock onto one solution
you unveil the next level of the problem
and so these this is the kind of thing
the design thinking loves to work on and
it's quite effective we've had
successful companies launched out of our
classes we've had successful problems
solutions created in the classes we have
a whole series of case studies up on the
d.school website that you can take a
look at but i want to start sort of
bringing this back over to the really
wicked problem and that's you know we've
had automobiles in our lives but we've
all had them for all of our lives with
automobiles since you know the turn of
the century and puppy there's never been
a time when cars are changing more than
they're changing now and you know it's a
it's certainly a multidisciplinary
problem there's all the issues of you
know making a vehicle that's good
transportation is comfortable to use but
their safety there's performance we have
an energy emerging energy crisis and our
reliance on fossil fuels has got to
diminish but we don't have effective
high intensity energy sources to replace
them yet let your cars are okay but
they're not quite there we've got all
these changing driver behaviors in one
of the things that Paul mentioned in the
introduction that Chris is working on is
you know can texting and driving be made
compatible it's interesting I'm sure you
know we've got a couple of hundred
people logged on to the webinar sure
many of you if I asked you have you ever
texted while driving would in if you
believe your answer was anonymous we
were doing a poll you would say yeah I
have and we all know that it's dangerous
but we all know it's a behavior that's
emerged recently that's probably the
meat that's going to have to be
fulfilled so how do we
all that problem and then cars of course
represents something in our culture and
who we are by you know which cars we
select the style with which we select
them and the society in which you know
we choose to deploy that persona so it's
a fantastic testbed for the kind of
design methodology that we use and chris
is I'll turn it over to Chris now he is
the head of the Center for Automotive
Research in Stanford I think a lot of
people don't realize that Stanford is
right now one of the really the Centers
of this type of research in the world
people think of Stanford for micro
processors and bioengineering and some
other things but Chris's lab has really
emerged as one of the leading research
focal points and so I'll turn it over to
Chris to talk about the really wicked
problem of designing the car the future
great thanks a lot bill I do want the
record to show that when I replied to
your text message this morning I was in
fact stopped at a stoplight and not
actively driving I wanted to kind of
build off of some of the things that
you're saying unlike a lot of my
colleagues in the Design Group I don't
do research in design theory what we do
however is what we say to try to have
safe clean fun in cars and so I got up
there a couple of images from our
research and advanced engine system that
we're looking at for a new type of
combustion that could be a much cleaner
on the Left we have an entirely student
built electric vehicle which is designed
to have steering and throttle brakes all
done by wire so we can actually
customize the handling of that vehicle
entirely and software and on the right
we have a car i'll talk about a little
bit later an Audi TTS that we're turning
into an autonomous race car and we have
approached these problems very much from
the standpoint of design thinking we
have in fact created a culture of
prototyping and as you can see we work
with large amounts of hardware now some
of the students who joined my lab have
done this forever one had his own
aftermarket auto parts company that he
ran while he was in undergrad and some
of them have ever never actually wielded
a wrench before in their lives and so
what we do try to do is
create this sense of creative confidence
by having people work not only with the
math but also with the actual cars you
know and sometimes it doesn't come
smoothly the first time somebody is very
good at math goes and decides are going
to change the tires they end up
scripting all the lug nuts and we have
to go replace those but what nuts are
replaceable and I think this sort of
experience is is not so what I wanted to
do was to talk a little bit just a
couple of examples from our research
about how we've taken this sort of
larger idea of design thinking and
applied it to produce some really
tangible results both for us and for our
sponsors that led to some significant
research advances so the first one I
want to talk about is our p1
steer-by-wire car and this has been the
workhorse of our lab for a number of
years it was entirely student built so
we had a team of five students that went
from a clean sheet of paper to the first
moving tests in about 15 months and as
you can see there are certain things
that we didn't do in that time frame we
ignored the rich Corinthian leather and
the body panels and things like that but
in fact the suspension the computers
everything has really been designed to
perform at an extremely high level here
we have independent front steering so
because we have a steer-by-wire system
where we've separated the actual
steering mechanically from the driver we
can turn the left and right wheel
independently we can do an alignment on
the fly we can in fact snowplow the
tires if we lose our brakes and do all
sorts of things with that we have
independent rear wheel drive so we can
actually steer it like a tank if we care
to do that and there's been a huge
number of research advances that have
come out of having this vehicle in our
lab for the last five years we've
learned some new things about how you
can stabilize his vehicle and prevent it
from spinning we've learned how to
actually estimate the friction between
the tire and the road before you're
using all of its your car in fact can
know its limits and respond
appropriately now this car will actually
drive itself it will race itself around
the track and we believe that it is a
first vehicle that is actually capable
of drifting by itself so it can put
itself into a sustained sideways drift
and hold it for an indefinite period of
time how do we necessarily had a lot of
competitors in this but but in fact we
feel over the
to have done that now what's interesting
is that this car has an has a history
starting as a diagnostic project so in
fact Nissan came to us and we had some
discussions about how to diagnose
failures in these steer-by-wire systems
we no longer have a mechanical
connection between the driver and the
steering system being able to make that
safe and diagnose errors becomes
absolutely critical so nice on came to
us we discussed this and said well how
about if you do a paper studied to start
and we said well no actually we want to
build a car so they reasonably asked why
we wanted to build a car and I told them
I'm sure we'll learn something at which
point they asked me what we've learned
and I told them we have absolutely no
idea but it's going to be important so
that was sort of a difficult thing to
take but it was an outgrowth of our
culture of prototyping we knew there was
something interesting there and we knew
that we would learn it by building by
getting students to have experience with
the entire system with a different
perspective than you're likely to get in
an automobile company so our partners in
crime here were de Beach and Craig
mulroy at the product realization lab
and they're a larger part of this
culture at Stanford in fact there they
often say that if you walk into the
product realization lab their job is to
help you build whatever you can envision
so I went to dave and craig and said hey
we we want to build a car and not
knowing any better they said sure so we
all launched off on on this project to
build a car not really knowing exactly
what we were doing well long the way we
had to design all aspects of this we had
to design the steering we had to design
the suspension instance we're going to
put students in the car we had to make
sure that things weren't going to break
so we spent a lot of time thinking about
what are the forces involved and we
realized well the suspension has to of
course handle all the forces coming from
the tires and the tires forces come from
the vehicle motion so in fact our
steering motor is really feeling the
vehicle motion like a trained race car
driver well our steering system knows by
how much torque is applying by what the
tire feels like exactly what's going on
with the vehicle and we said hey wait a
minute this is an idea that we can do
for diagnosis we can measure what the
vehicles doing how it's moving we can
measure what the steering thinks the
vehicle is doing based upon this torque
and
compare the two there's a comparison
here that we can use to check to see if
there's any failure in the steering
system well we presented this at a
project review meeting and realized that
there was a bit of a clash of cultures
here so I have up a schematic the
specifics of this aren't aren't
specifically important but our sponsors
were responsible for the electrical
elements and the mechanical elements of
this year by wire system now as is
typical when you have to do a large
project like an automobile it's
important that the team has some focus
and has some boundaries around what
they're considering so this was kind of
the way the world looked to them their
responsibility for the batteries the
dc-to-dc converter that would allow them
to run a motor controller the motor the
sensors that they were going to use to
to actually figure out where the
steering was at any given time and that
was their view of of the system we came
back and said we'll wait a minute
there's a car here and in fact we can
measure what the car is doing and our
systems level perspective is in fact
broader we can use that knowledge to
have information go back and forth
between what the car is doing and what
the steering electronics are doing and
this originally seemed like a kind of a
strange idea because if you understand
electrical components they have a lot of
nice properties they're really fast
they're easily modeled and they're
fairly certain whereas the vehicle
dynamics themselves are much more
complicated and subject to a lot of
disturbances of noise how many people do
you have in your car did you throw the
golf clubs in the back are your tires
inflated are you driving in the rain all
of these things that make this
connection difficult to understand so we
were in fact proposing that you take
this wonderfully compact system that's
easily explained and by understanding
its connection to this more complicated
more difficult to understand system
there would be some value so at the end
of a very long meeting where our
sponsors fired questions at us have long
discussions and Japanese fired more
questions at us went back and forth I
asked where they stood and they said
well we're skeptical but very interested
so we went ahead and built this and as
it turns out this will
greatly successful we were able to
diagnose faults that were below the
level of human perception so we could
put somebody in the car they could drive
we could introduce a small problem with
the steering system that they didn't
even feel and as a result we were able
to then pull out and show them that the
system had managed to sense a small
discrepancy despite the the uncertainty
in the vehicle dynamics we could still
use these sorts of techniques now this
is a sort of a great cooperation with
Nissan we had a variety of folks from
Nissan come and drive the car this is a
picture of CEO carlos going coming and
taking the car out for a spin it's
epitomize our collaboration with Nissan
we've just recently ended about a two
year stay of a visiting researcher who
came from Nissan and work directly in my
lab and really was a fantastic fantastic
lab member so one of the things that is
interested them is just our approach to
problems the way that we're able to take
design thinking ideas and come up with
very specific engineering innovations as
a result of that so the second story I'd
like to talk about is involving our
development of driver assistance systems
so one of the ongoing questions that we
have in the lab is how do we assist even
the best drivers in avoiding accidents
and this is a difficult problem because
in fact if you look at polls generally
about seventy nine eighty percent of
people consider themselves to be above
average drivers about 20 or so percent
consider themselves average and usually
get about one percent of people who feel
that they need help and are below
average drivers so if we're going to
make driver assistance systems how do we
get past the idea that people feel that
they don't really need this sort of help
and so our solution of this is to think
about how can we assist even the best
drivers and now how do we do this well
again consistent with our culture of
prototyping with the idea of iteration
asking questions our desire is to build
a car that drives like the very best
drivers so on the right here I've
Illustrated our Audi TTS we've
officially affectionately nicknamed the
car Shelley after michele mouton who is
the first woman win the Pikes Peak Hill
Climb driving an Audi and
goal is then to use this project this
whole idea of can we design a car that
can race itself around a track whether
it be a dirt track or a paved track can
we use that challenge as a way of
understanding how to support drivers so
I have a brief video of some of the
testing that we've done on this car
which I think shows a little bit about
the the culture of of how we do this
you'll see the the team out in the
bonneville salt flats and this was
actual footage taken during some of our
testing
that gives you a little bit of a sense
of what it's like on the project those
are scenes that we took when we were out
testing and salt flats in fact scene
where the car drives off by itself with
no one inside was the first time we had
ever tried that that was actually
captured on film we have a very special
team working on this and bill mentioned
radical collaboration the team that we
have together on this project involves
faculty graduate students undergraduates
at Stanford it involves engineers from
Volkswagen and Audi and Oracle and we
were all together out on the salt flats
testing the car the tents that it showed
it was in fact are our only shelter on
the salt flats for a period of about a
week or two weeks as we go out and do
this sort of testing so it does take a
very special group of dedicated people
to go out and test in these conditions
to work together as a team despite the
fact that things are not working and
that's always someone's fault right it's
either the software that's not working
or the hardware that's not working how
do you get past that how do you work
together as a team that's one of the
other things that we think we can learn
from racing this whole analogy where you
have to get the car to perform out on
the track everyone has to work together
is a beautiful way of thinking about
teamwork about how you can execute the
radical collaboration now beyond that
one of the things that we're learning
from this project is where machines have
an advantage over even skilled drivers
as we've attempted to reconstruct in
some ways what human race car drivers do
we've learned some areas where they have
some advantages we've learned some areas
where the computer has an advantage we
think as we continue to dial in on these
things we can really develop driver
assistance systems that will help even
the best drivers that will do things
that even the most talented race car
drivers find to be tremendously
challenging and even those eighty
percent or so of above average drivers
on the road would have great difficulty
doing so from this project we're already
seeing how this gets into systems that
can prevent accidents and we're putting
all of that information back
to our colleagues at audi and volkswagen
so that's a little bit about what what
we do and the way that we do it and i
think i guess we have a break before
questions will will certainly be
welcoming questions we've seen a few
questions come in via the chat function
so feel free to consider questions for
Chris and we're going to turn it back
over to Bill Burnett yeah I have a
question for you Chris you know I saw in
the video the Audi doing these you know
four wheeled drifts spinning the Audi
logo in the in the sand out there was
that what were those experiments that
you had designed in advance or how did
you just how did you decide what to do
when you got out to the Salt Flats well
that's actually a really good question
in putting together the video we had
some ideas that came in from actually
the video team about things that could
be done and what was interesting was
working together with the video team
they said you know it's actually not
important whether the car can can do it
itself we can just make it look like the
car is doing it itself and I said no
that's that doesn't work at all or a
research group we pride ourselves on
credibility there cannot be one thing
that you show in the video that the car
is doing that we haven't done
autonomously that we haven't done with
the car itself and so as a result we did
things like you know they wanted to see
where it shoots across the salt flats at
about 130 miles an hour so we had itself
we had the car drive itself at 130 miles
an hour across the salt flats that
actually wasn't originally planned but
they wanted to show it and so we got
that going they had the idea sort of
drifting the Audi rings which was a huge
huge hit with our sponsors that image
has has has really been an enduring one
from the from the project and so we we
developed the program to enable it to go
in and drift the drift the Rings it
turned out at the last minute when they
did the helicopter shot suddenly we had
to reverse the entire pattern and so we
literally with a helicopter
in the air reprogrammed the path to get
the car to do it in the other direction
changed all of the boundaries and the
markings and executed what you see there
on the video so has it had you ever
ridden driven the car at 130 miles an
hour before you know that was new no
soon okay that was new so in addition to
radical collaboration you need a little
bit of radical courage it sounds like
and I also you're talking about you know
building cars that can do you know what
the best drivers do and I know you
mentioned the Pikes Peak challenge
what's this what's the status of Shelley
right now and visa V the Pikes Peak
challenge well so last September we we
did some preliminary testing there are
huge logistical challenges to testing on
on Pikes Peak so Pikes Peak is a
publicly open road they close it for the
hill climb and in fact we closed it for
our testing so there are no other
vehicles on there it's about a 12 point
four mile stretch of switchbacks some
part of its paved part of its dirt and
it goes up to about 14,000 feet with
with no guardrails and some sheer
drop-offs so we wanted to make sure that
we could get our position information
from GPS that we would have reasonable
enough maps to drive up there and so in
September we went and we ran it with a
lead vehicle in a chase vehicle just to
make sure that the the path was clear it
is crisscrossed with hiking trails and
we did occasionally find hikers
unexpectedly on on the road and have to
pause the task but with the lead and
chase vehicles we ran it up and down six
times without anybody in the car so we
got a good understanding of what it
takes to to run on Pikes Peak we've been
continuing to develop it we were using a
dynamics pad at infineon just about a
week ago trying to see how close we are
to the actual theoretical limits of how
fast the car can go and then our plan is
to continue to go on with with some
testing on tracks and then once we get
everything dialed in hopefully we can go
back to Pikes Peak intestines feed and I
know you've been working with Professor
cliff mass
on some of this sort of social issues
and we mentioned texting inclusive spent
a lot of research on multitasking and
texting and things you talked a little
bit about you know the car in society in
this notion of autonomous vehicles or
just even autonomous machines and kind
of the research questions that you're
looking at there sure I think one of the
things that we've been establishing in
our research is what can we do what are
the limits what are the possibilities
that we can do with driver assistance
systems and what what are the technical
capabilities as we've established those
it's become increasingly apparent that a
lot of the interesting questions are
what should we do and as you go back and
forth between cars where the driver is
fully responsible for everything and
cars where the car is responsible for
everything those are two easy concepts
to understand but one of the great
challenges is how do you do anything in
between how do you begin to get a car to
work cooperatively with the driver what
sort of capabilities can you take away
from the driver without having to tune
out of the driving process entirely and
if we do start to support how do you
have the car and the driver understand
each other the car has some perception
of the environment it wants to take
actions that it thinks are safe how do
you get that level of understanding
across to the driver and there's some
very interesting theories out there in
fact treating the autonomous vehicle
like a horse the understanding of how
you get these two intellects together to
negotiate these sorts of safety issues
and I think working with cliff is a
great example of radical collaboration
he's approaching this from the
standpoint of human machine interaction
from communications and being able to
work together with with his students
which we do in a driving simulator is a
great opportunity thanks Paul I think
our Krista we're going to turn it back
to you for a moment and then as we get
more questions will be typing our
answers and a couple of the questions
that are coming up we'll get back to
with a verbal answer for everybody
great thank you very much bill just hold
on just a second so there we go so we
have a program that we're offering this
June and as part of the the scpd's
annual set of offerings the we're
providing this innovation master series
we provided a successful iteration last
June and we're rerunning this version 2
point 0 where we actually have taken a
design thinking approach to delivering
this workshop some of the important
values I think whether it's a strategy a
product or a service students who attend
this program will certainly be
benefiting from many of the senior
faculty and Design Group and at the
d.school and we're looking forward to
greeting teams and working on specific
problems this one the Stanford center
for professional development has been a
part of the School of Engineering and it
has been fostering a tradition in
education for companies across the globe
and in a variety of different industries
in the School of Engineering we take
very seriously the the research and
education interactions that we have with
industry and as part of our effort we
bridge and offer industry students
graduate as well as professional
education programs and the innovation
master series is part of that offering
we've been delivering education for over
40 years to industry and we look forward
to perhaps even seeing many of you in
the program that we have here this
summer it will be on jun 15 to 17 2011
as i mentioned will be three days of
intensive hands-on workshops this is not
a series of lectures that's designed
much more in the radical collaboration
mode where you'll be working either with
teammates or with others in the course
we have some additional details here
which we think might be of interest for
those of you who
or are thinking about coming Eve by our
young who's associate director you've
heard from her her contact information
is up there and there's some benefit if
you register before april eighth now who
should attend this program as i
mentioned the the offering really spans
the spectrum from executives and senior
leaders who are thinking about how to do
this as a potential innovation
implementation against strategy to folks
who are an RD may be struggling to
getting the same old results using the
same mold processes to actually
innovation leaders who who have a great
idea who perhaps are thinking out of the
proverbial box but just don't have the
tools and techniques or the team
responding in the way that they should
so these are the kinds of folks that
have attended previous programs and
would greatly benefit from the activity
that we have in June some of the key
program takeaways really a we're trying
to to teach how to implement innovation
so it becomes part of the culture you
heard Chris and Bill also talk about
this notion that it's not just one
individual but it takes a community of
diverse perspectives in order to create
and nurture really innovative ideas
we'll talk a lot about how to build and
nurture this radical collaboration how
to have a sort of use empathy to get new
ideas from your customers observation
skills that will be needed to generate
new ideas and finally this notion of
prototyping having fun with this I think
Chris mentioned in at the outset the
notion of of having fun we often spend
most of our working lives with the
people in the office and if you're not
having fun which you is how can that
change we hope that this course might
give some insights along those lines we
have a great group of senior faculty
from the d.school as well as from
mechanical engineering and the design
division you see a number of them listed
here a few notable said bill mentioned
David Kelley who is a founder of I do we
sometimes think about I do
as another terrific Stanford spin out
that to some extent those techniques and
inside subsp on back into the university
benefiting the students and connecting
domains such as business computer
science mechanical engineering
Electrical Engineering to evolve
solutions that are unique different and
will have lasting and disruptive impact
you heard from bill and Chris Bernie
Roth is another faculty member who is a
co-director of the hassle platter
institute of design so it's a really a
stellar cast and I think one of the
other benefits that you'll have is
interactions with these faculty on a
one-on-one basis throughout the program
really really valuable and not a lot of
people get that kind of visibility and
so with with that presentation would
love to get a sense from you all of you
on line what's your interest level in
the innovation master series course that
we're offering here in June we have a
I'm ready to enroll a couple of other
selections I'm interested but would like
to receive more information we were
certainly happy to follow up with you
and Eve is available to follow up with
additional information we also welcome
teams this notion that just one hidden
person in a group who know these
innovation techniques may not be enough
to actually create the kind of change
and impact that you're seeking as a
selection here I'm interested but unable
to intend in June we have some evolving
online offerings that may be able to
fulfill your interest in this domain and
obviously you're not interested in that
at this time so if you could make your
selection that pole will remain open
wanted to again just to leave this slide
up and I'm going to actually turn it
back over to to Bill and to Chris to
answer a few of your questions that have
come in that have piqued their interest
so hang on the line we're heading to
questions right now we have a number of
questions that have come in over the
chat and we'll try to answer all of them
but there's three or four that I think
are general interest to everybody so
one of the first ones that came in is
you know thinking about the driver
assistance systems and controls can we
build a car that continuously teaches or
instructs the driver to become a better
driver so that with time behind the
wheel the drivers skill increases Chris
what's your thought on that I think
that's an absolutely great idea this is
something that cliff and I have talked
about partially in the in the realm of
racing in fact BMW has had a system
which they call the track trainer where
they drive a car around the track with
an expert driver and then it temps to
Train somebody to follow that what we
thought about is something that could be
very interactive where in fact your car
learns about you you learn about the car
and you have this way of developing
trust over time which in an emergency
situation the car has a sense of how
you're going to respond you have a sense
of how the car is going to respond and
you increase safety in this way one of
the questions we have is you know how
much of this applies to to normal
driving as well because most of the time
you're not driving in emergency
situations so how do we get the
understanding this sense of trust from
ordinary situations and take that out
into the extreme situation so I think
there is potential there I think this is
absolutely a great question and a great
idea you know you're brought up the
notion of imagining the car is like a
horse and as a horse rider I now not
only need to learn the techniques of
controlling the horse and getting the
horse to do what I want but I have to
respond to the horse I'm on because a
choice has a different personality and a
slightly different way of liking to be
controlled and it sort of strikes me
that this is that it's the same it's a
brilliant analogy because it's the same
situation in the car every car is
different and as you said the car
responds differently when the pavement
sweat when the tires aren't inflated so
it's really a relationship with the car
be people talk about having a
relationship with their car nowadays
more like well I like my car like the
way it looks I think it's cute or I like
the color or you know I bought it
because it seems like it's my kind of
car but do you imagine that as as cars
become more and more intelligent that
relationship you know changes and
becomes more of a mutual one
well I think we need to manage that I
think one of the big challenges it's
been seen recently with the concerns
about unintended acceleration in Toyotas
is how poorly people do understand their
cars a lot of the reports that came out
these thousands of reports of problems
with the car many of them translated to
a misunderstanding of what the car was
supposed to do it was doing something in
fact it was designed to do there's other
cases where the person was impact
hitting the wrong pedal now there's a
lack of understanding i think over the
years and you know not to blame people
engineers have done a pretty poor job of
communicating what the car is supposed
to do so as we get into these more
intelligent systems I think that really
is the key issue how does the car
communicate what it's doing says the
person can really better understand and
you were involved with the Toyota
situation you were brought in I think as
one of the experts to look at the data
so Toyota asked me to take a look at
some of what had been presented in
congressional testimony so I got access
to anything in the in the company to
look at in terms of the warranty records
the engineering data and things like
things like that and it's a it's a
really interesting story about people
not necessarily understanding technology
and not understand their own limitations
in some ways and in fact when people do
hit the wrong pedal that doesn't
register in their brain they know they
know they hit the brake because in fact
that's what they intended to hit but
just for the same reason that you can't
hit a free throw the same way every time
in really stressful situations sometimes
we make errors with with positioning and
we don't correct them because we know
with absolute certainty that we're
pushing on the gas when in fact that's
not the case we know we were pushing
hard on something there was another
question that came let's see you want oh
I'm project team size now is there an
optimal number of participants so the
idea that large project teams require
additional administration and that's
definitely an obstacle so how do we move
these sorts of ideas from from the lab
or from the small research group into
industry what's what has been your
experience of that bill well there's a
lot of research both around
entrepreneurship
a creative teams team size is what's an
optimal team you know we find for
instance the teams that get teams to get
too large we talk about
multidisciplinary radicals collaboration
but when the teams get too large they
need to be broken in two sub-teams
there's a lot of evidence that says
entrepreneurial teams that entrepreneurs
the individual entrepreneurs are not as
effective as pairs and pears are the
most effective way to sort of launch new
ideas that says with a seed an
entrepreneur there are preparing to
their more robust in the sensitive one
entrepreneur drops out you have a
redundant system so around
entrepreneurship we know that teams of
two are the best in terms of teams of
retsoor radical collaboration teams
teams to get larger in any subgroup
larger than five to seven it's difficult
to brainstorm it's difficult to have you
know open communication is difficult for
everybody to be in the same you know
meetings or the same room at the same
time now obviously it takes a bigger
team than that to design you know the
kinds of vehicles that you're designing
so how do you handle the complexity of
large-scale teams and outside partners
and inside partners that's a good
question and this is I mean it continues
to be a challenge for us we do work a
lot in individual groups i have my grad
students and there's certain aspects of
the project that that we tend to
brainstorm on and then we connect with
our colleagues at Volkswagen and Audi in
in larger meetings as as well and we try
to kind of mix up the the group to some
extent so when we go out testing we
don't necessarily bring an entire army
of people who are working on the project
but the people who are involved change
so that folks are getting exposure to
aspects of the project that they weren't
aware of we try to make the boundaries
between these different groups fairly
permeable and so I like your your answer
of like five to seven that often seems
to be the the group size that we work
with obviously if we're out away from
campus we need to bring more people
because we need to support more
activities but we try to kind of mix up
who those five to seven people are as we
go
the project yeah I like to use a music
analogy if you think about the
difference between a great jazz quintet
and a full-blown symphony orchestra a
jazz quintet which is sort of the my
model for innovation five people or you
know for three to five people in any
jazz combo they can see each other they
can respond to each other immediately
they know the music that they know what
they're going to do when they start
playing will change every time and but
they are so good at their individual
instruments are so so good at their
individual professional piece that they
can improvise in the moment and there's
a confidence that they have amongst each
other when you get to the size of an
orchestra then you need a conductor and
everybody needs to be playing off the
same score so I think you want and
there's another question about you know
how do you how do you tackle a large
product project with you how do you
break a project into manageable tasks
think of it think of that analogy the
places in the project where you need
lots and lots of coordination everybody
needs to be working from the same
project brief from the same schedule
from this working on the same milestones
that gives organization as the conductor
conducts that organization but where you
need breakthroughs and innovations and
you may need it in multiple places you
want to break your team's down into
small jazz you know combos who can
respond and improvise on the moment like
when you're out in the salt flats and
suddenly the guy in the helicopter says
can't film it that way could you rewrite
all the software and make it go
backwards you know you need to be able
to improvise in the moment and so you
know it's a challenge in large
organizations because you're not to do
typically not set up around project
teams project focus your set up in you
know functional groups and you don't
have the opportunity to to be that
improvisational so one of the things
that happens when you move this out of
academics and into the organization to
really have to look at some
organizational behavior and
organizational structure issues on this
project basis we do have another program
that addresses some of this and how
teams and portfolios of projects roll up
and I like the Jazz analogy where if you
can break up these teams but also you
have a conductor someone who's in charge
that can aggregate those
pieces that can in essence pull the the
jazz quartet quintet together that's a
really important perspective one that we
deal with quite a bit here at Stanford
in another program one thing that we've
used which has been really effective is
to learn from the the space program and
in fact we've adopted kind of a mission
orientation so when we have to figure
out how are we going to run the project
we think of the project is a series of
missions each one of which will involve
certain functionalities from different
teams so if you want to use the Jazz
analogy we kind of build albums so you
figure out what is each team necessary
to get done for this particular mission
and if it's not it's not going to get
done it flies on the next mission and
how can we sequence these things so that
the team's see how they fit together and
yet everybody's gone and immediate drive
not oh I've got to deliver this because
somewhere down the road it's going to be
useful we try to make sure that we have
these intermediate steps where everybody
can participate in it their work is
useful very quickly great well thank you
Bill and Chris for that wonderful
question and answer session well that
concludes today and I'd like to thank
everyone for joining us for the design
thinking and cars a future webinar